The conference central application includes both a back-end
application that defines the end point function and front-end
application that has the web page users functions. So
I'm going to call the back-end application, basically I'm going to
refer to it as the back-end API and the
part of the application that has the web pages
I'm going to refer to as the web UI.
In our case, they're all in one single application.
Got one app ID, we deploy the app, takes the back-end API and takes web the
web UI with it. However, the web UI and the back-end API don't have to be in
the same application. They could be in completely
separate applications, or you could even have multiple applications,
that provide different front-end interfaces to the conference
back-end API. So here we've got several different applications,
each with a different kind of Web UI and we
have our conference API running here on the back-end API. However
in our case the web UI and the back-end API
are in the same application. But our opinion doesn't really care
that they're in the same application. You still have to
authorize a front-end UI to access the back-end API. So, those
are a few things that you need to do before
you can start using the web pages in the Conference Central
application and these are all around authorizing the web UI for
login and giving the web UI permission to use the back-end API